and joining us now the US Surgeon
General Vice Admiral Jerome Adams dr.
Adams the u.s. is now reporting 30,000
new cases a day and I want to put up a
chart that shows the curve of cases in
Italy and China which have leveled off
and are now going down and the curve on
the far right they're here in the US
which is still in the early stages and
still headed up sharply given the course
of the disease in China and Italy and
that we are weeks or months behind them
how bad is this epidemic going to be in
America and how long will it last
well it's tragically fitting that we're
talking at the beginning of Holy Week
because this is going to be the hardest
and the saddest week of most Americans
lives quite frankly this is going to be
our Pearl Harbor moment our 9/11 moment
only it's not going to be localized it's
going to be happening all over the
country and I want America to understand
that but I also want them to understand
that the public along with the state and
the federal government have the power to
change the trajectory of this epidemic
you mentioned Italy and Spain they had a
very very hard time and they're still
having a hard time but they seem to have
reached their peak and are coming back
down on the other side and you say weeks
months behind
I would actually push back a little bit
when you look at their trajectory from
about a month ago is when they really
started to lean into their aggressive
mitigation efforts they're really
aggressive mitigation efforts and so I
want Americans to understand that it's
harder this week is going to be there is
a light at the end of the tunnel if
everyone does their part for the next 30
days we're seeing Washington actually
where this started doing a much better
job
California's trajectory has leveled off
and so there is hope but we've got to
all do our part
but let's talk about mitigation because
the president's top health advisors
including you say the most important
thing we can do all of us is to stay at
home and yet there are still have nine
states there are still nine states with
millions of Americans that still have
not issued stay at home orders that
President Trump was asked about that
this week here he is the governor's the
governor's know what they're doing
they've been doing a great job I guess
with close to 90 percent anyway and
states that we're talking about are not
in jeopardy now I would leave it to the
governor's but dr. Adams the coronavirus
is not a state issue it doesn't follow
or respect state borders
dr. pouchy says he believes that there
should be a national stay at home order
is he wrong well Chris it's important to
understand that most people across the
country are doing the right thing over
ninety percent of the country is staying
at home and a good proportion more than
average is staying home even in those
nine states but the last time you and I
talked it was about opioids people don't
know but I've run a State Department of
Health I've been involved in health for
years and diseases don't respect it to
state lines but we live in a country
where we have a system of federalism and
when it comes to opioids states have
different rules and regulations and laws
regarding treatment regarding syringe
service programs as you and I have
talked about I actually put out a report
on tobacco cessation earlier this year
and we know that states have different
laws there and more people will die even
in the worst projections from cigarette
smoking in this country that are going
to die from from coronavirus this year
and so we always are struggling with
trying to get information out to guide
people that we know will help them be
healthy with states rights but it's why
we put out these 30 days to stop the
spread guidelines these are essentially
our national stay at home order and
we're working with governors to figure
out their needs their desires one more
important point the nine states that
haven't yet
dunh dunnhhhh shelter-in-place orders
are states that actually produce a large
amount of our food so they're struggling
with issues concerning how they can
provide for the rest of the country to
be able to stay at home but right now my
what I would say to those governors is
if you can't give us a month
give us what you can give us a week give
us whatever you can to stay at home
during it's particularly tough time when
we're going to be hitting our peak over
the next next seven to ten days but
doctor but dr. Adams is a big difference
between opioids and and cigarettes which
are something that people decide to use
or not to use and the coronavirus which
people catch it's not an individual
choice and and you know when president
Trump says that he's a wartime president
during World War two FDR didn't say well
it's up to each state to decide what to
do he mobilized the nation again why not
a national stay at home order the the
corona virus doesn't recognize states
rights so does the federal analogy
really work here well Chris I know a
week ago is forever in Kiruna virus time
but I would remind people that it was
just a week ago when the idea of a
federal quarantine for the New York City
area was being floated in Governor Cuomo
said that would be like declaring war on
the states the governors are intensely
protective of their right and rightly so
to be able to decide what's best for
their states and we're gonna do
everything we can as scientist in its
physicians as medical professionals to
help them understand what we think the
right thing is for them to do and so I
just want everyone to know that from a
national perspective the Surgeon General
is saying no matter where you are stay
at home at least give us a week or two
if you can we want you to do it for 30
days but even in those nine states give
us what you can so we can get this peak
and start to come down on the other side
dr. Adams for days President Trump has
been talking about hydroxychloroquine as
a possible treatment for people with the
corona virus but yesterday in his
briefing he took it even further take a
look what do you have to lose in some
cases they're in bad shape what do you
have to lose I may take it and I'll have
to ask my doctors about that but I may
take it dr. Adams as the nation's top
public health official are you
comfortable with people taking an
unproven untested drug even people who
don't actually have the virus well
here's what we've advised the president
and here's what I've heard him say
consistently when people are in a tragic
situation were they there in the
hospital or a loved one's in the
hospital with Kovan 19 we want them to
be able to have a conversation with
their health care provider about
everything that they could possibly do
to save their lives there is some
accounts some stories out there
regarding hydroxychloroquine helping and
we know it's been available for years so
we feel a little bit better regarding
its safety than we do about a completely
novel drug even though this is being
used at much higher dosages and so we
just want to be able to facilitate
physicians and patients having that
conversation that's what I tell people
that's what I've heard the president
tell people finally and I got about a
minute left here dr. Adams the CDC now
recommends that people use face
coverings in public and in fact you're
in a CDC video in which you show people
how to make a mask themselves that they
can wear but President Trump was clear
that he is not going to be following
that guidance take a look here sir I
think wearing a face mask as I greet
presidents prime ministers dictators
kings queens I don't know somehow I
don't see it for myself does that
statement by the president send a mixed
message about taking this recommendation
seriously well if you look at the CDC
guidelines they actually emphasize that
number one they're voluntary and number
two and the most important part of this
is they're not a substitute for social
distancing I was at the White House
yesterday I'm going there immediately
after this the White House doctors and
Secret Service are taking pains to make
sure everyone is social distancing in
regards to the president and the vice
president and each other and so the
president is making a choice that's
appropriate for him what I want
Americans to know is if you're going out
in public and you're gonna be closer
than six feet to other people you can
use a cloth facial covering and here's
mine that I made very easy to use and it
protects you from me we want people to
understand you're wearing this not to
protect you to yourself you're using it
to protect your neighbor and that's what
this week is going to be all about
people staying at home to protect their
neighbor people wearing cloth facial
coverings if they have to go out in
public to protect their neighbor it's
gonna be a test of our resolve it's
gonna be the test of our lives but I am
confident that we can come out on the
other side based on the data and based
on what I know about the American people
dr. Adams thank you thanks for your time
during these very busy days please come
back sir
thank you